hi my name is Audrey and I'm Chloe and
we're seven years old and today Two
Chefs are gonna be competing to make our
Dream outer space dish three two one
and I'm Alex I have a question for you
if you were going to a birthday party on
Mars what food would you want to eat I
would maybe drink a like outer space
drink it's a purple and it has little
pieces of stars in it Mexico a little
crazy
I'm telling a flower Panic what do you
like to eat no I like to eat donuts what
are the best flavors on the flower
Planet strawberry lavender lavender do
you like vanilla and chocolate too yeah
I love
the picture is very creative so I'm
excited to be creative as well the next
thing I'm gonna draw is the ice cream
Planet Stars tastes delicious since they
make wishes oh it's a cookie that has
little stars on it and it's a big star
and after stars are on what does it
taste like it tastes like a normal
cookie but like in the middle there will
be a filling have you eaten a star
before no no yes oh you did are you
excited for a space party yeah yeah how
about we wish upon a star and then blast
off so three three two one
[Music]
whoa are you ready I am are you I've
always wanted to go to space so I'm not
interested really they say there's two
kinds of people people who want to go to
deep sea and people who want to go to
deep space I don't want to go gonna take
some risks today but you know what we're
in space yeah so we gotta just have fun
always oh I enjoy your cookies back yay
jump is here as always I am so excited
to do this show with Ria and to get to
cook alongside her like old times I'm
going to start with ice cream Planet
because I need some prep time yeah I'm
going to start with flower planner
listen in this competition I am not
above picnics
food coloring yeah these are kids
they're taste buds is very sensitive yes
they don't like complicated flavor I do
wonder if I'm at a disadvantage now in
this competition because Ria is a mom I
feel more confident after I have a child
but at the same time my son is the
pickiest boy in the world I still think
of myself as a child though so maybe I
can relate to the judges a little better
I'm scooping ice cream and making like a
sphere I'm Gonna Bake My Cake on a sheet
tray just because I want it to bake
faster I need like a pretty good volume
of cake so I'm just gonna make another
one and put it right back on here I got
a bunch of different fruits and I'm
gonna start cutting Ria has been making
things from scratch with a lot of
natural ingredients at first I was a
little intimidated but then I remembered
that the judges are kids so I know my
audience I'm just gonna try to make it
like kind of galaxy-ish by just putting
like I put a little black a little blue
oh a lot of purple this looks cool it's
like a Galaxy swirly Galaxy read do you
want to go to space I don't why I love
ours we have to make sure ours doesn't
fall apart and like we don't need to go
like what do you do in space just chill
you know Vibe you can chill in a beach
you have to drink your own urine no you
don't no like I went to NASA
I wholeheartedly believe in aliens I
don't need to go out to seek a band they
can come to me yeah and you see me I was
at the Hollywood Bowl last night and I
swear I saw UFOs she was explaining what
happened but it's just over my head my
swirly Galaxy cake is ready to bake I'm
using this pineapple for the Galaxy
drink as you can see I'm back on another
box of cake mix Alex is using a lot of
snowball stuff I think it is actually a
good strategy because kids loved sweet
stuff this time I'm going to add a
little bit less liquid because I'm going
to do a hack where you use cake mix to
make cookie dough this is for the star
cookie so I'm now cutting mango I love
mango do you want to eat yeah okay
remember the good old tasty days yeah
all the time we sat next to each other
at first I think you were like oh God
who is this girl sitting next to me like
can I move and then at some point he
just accepted it that's not how I
remember but okay I have these like neon
mixed sprinkles they're little stars I
remember you are always so fast I'll be
making a lot of mistakes and I need the
extra time once a day what's a story
called The Tortoise and hair I just try
to work fast because I know there's
gonna be a point where I messed
something up so I want to leave myself
extra time for that to happen now I'm
going to make stock cooking I'm going to
be moving on to my ice cream Planet I
have these fun like Cookie Crunch blue
ice cream and this one is mermaid
Sparkle ice cream I need it like
patchier because like the Earth it's
like green and blue swirl I added egg
into my butter mixture and then I'm
gonna sift in flour in my mind this was
an amazing idea in reality
it's fine my cookie dough is done so I'm
going to put this in a refrigerator
[Music]
I'm just going to start tearing this
into pieces I really want to go Larger
than Life with my dish today so I'm
thinking some sort of giant cake pop as
a planet go to space or go home
I had to go home I am going to make base
of flower planet and I have tofu I have
mochiko oh Mochi donut yeah and squeeze
some lemon juice Ria is pulling out tofu
if we're supposed to be providing
nutritional value to these kids then I'm
going to lose I want to win but I also
don't want to give too much sugar I have
this like space glue vanilla frosting
again I haven't made a giant cake pop
ever so this is definitely not going on
a stick like a normal cake pop would but
I'm gonna try to like maneuver some sort
of stand for it so can you still call it
cake pop
this is kind of more difficult than I
imagined it kind of breaks apart because
this cake pop is so massive its weight
is kind of crushing on itself how about
using plastic mop oh good idea but Ria
gave me a really genius tip to use
plastic wrap which really helps me get
that sphere shape I'm just needing my
donut dough until everything gets loose
I'm going to rest in a refrigerator and
I'm going to roll out my cookie dough
just cut out stir have some go yeah are
you gonna eat you know like I don't I
don't eat cookie dough I think it's
American thing you don't eat cookie
dough no it's so good she has this
shooting star coming out of her drink so
I figured it would be cool to do like a
sugar one I was just gonna use a Jolly
Rancher and melt it down so it would fit
in the star we only had a very small
metal star cookie cutter so I realized
that my Jolly Rancher wouldn't quite fit
inside it Ria suggested that I smash it
with a rolling pin
[Music]
hard
that Jolly Ranchers were so dangerous
okay I'm gonna put some of my Jolly
Rancher shrapnel in here and I just want
it to like melt down into its star so
I'm going to cut out rice paper in a
flower shape this rice paper flowers
I saw on Tick Tock and it looked easy
enough it's very difficult to cut it's
like breaking Maria is so talented and
I'm not used to seeing her make mistakes
but she's kind of struggling with the
rice paper flowers I wish I could help
you here but I don't know what you're
doing I'm gonna use edible flowers for
this reason easy enough how about that
does it look like flour yeah okay it's
like a star flower which is perfect yeah
from here I think I can kind of trim
into soccer like this is becoming like a
craft not cooking now I'm moving on
finally to my mirror place I have my
gelatin sheet and they need to bloom and
so I'm gonna add in water sugar and
sweetened condensed milk and I'm gonna
grab my gelatin and squeeze out all of
the extra water skills like a dead
jellyfish pop this into my sugar mixture
so it can dissolve now I'm going to pour
my hot mixture over this broken up white
chocolate and I want it to be hot enough
for it to melt the chocolate along with
it blend up the white chocolate into my
mixture through the Galaxy mirror glaze
is something that's really finicky and
hard to do I know that from experience
but I just want to go for it today I
think this might work I'm gonna make
small donuts and I'm gonna make two big
Donuts so I have some safety net I'm
going to make Mochi fall my ice cream
Planet I add mochiko and the sugar and
I'm lightly mixing add water mix now I'm
going to microwave this until it becomes
sticky and stretchy so I've separated my
mirror glaze into five different bowls
and I'm just going to be coloring them
different variations from black to Blue
to purple to Pink my cookie is a little
softer and I'm cutting inside with
another star shape my cookie is out from
the oven and I'm going to stuff with
Gummy Bear my Mochi came out from the
microwave I'm gonna add a color hope
this was a good idea it doesn't look
cute and be very careful when you're
making Mochi sticky it's so sticky and
it's very very hot you have to be very
careful roll this Mochi you have to use
a bunch of cornstarch potato starch you
also have to do it while it's hot wow
look that is beautiful yay thank you I
have ice cream and I'm going to just
wrap I have my cake planet
out good as it's gonna get my glaze is
at temperature I'm gonna pour each of
these into the other this is chaotic I'm
gonna pour this on
wish me luck
choosing to do the Galaxy mirror glaze
was a big risk I took in this
competition
I think that's the quietest I've ever
been
now I'm just gonna pour a bunch of white
food coloring and I'm just gonna take a
paintbrush and kind of flick it so I'm
just trying to wrap my Mochi around the
ice cream about it stopped melting so I
have to move very quickly and kind of
twist on the bottom so close the bottom
and put it on the ice cream and I'm
gonna freeze this again I hope it
doesn't fall off maybe I should transfer
it to like a plate
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's going in the fridge now I'm going
to fry this rice paper hoppy walks
oh no when I was trying to fry the rice
paper I was calling up and it doesn't
look like flour at all the second one I
was also hoping it's Gonna Keep the
shape but it doesn't so I think
hopefully it is going to work using two
spiders and I'm going to place lightly
is it working I think oh
yes
nice I was able to make flower shape I'm
happy with my star cookies they came out
cute so I'm just gonna take the inside
of the cookie and carefully just put
this marshmallow fluff right in the
middle and clean up the star shape next
thing I made my star Jolly Rancher and
I'm not exactly sure how I'm gonna get
this out of the cookie cutter
unfortunately I forgot to put any like
cooking spray or oil on the cookie
cutter we had a heat gun that I was able
to use I've never used one of these
before it's always a great thing to say
okay well this Heat Gun Works really
quickly I also sprayed it with cooking
spray to hopefully get it easier to
remove it actually ended up burning the
oil it's not looking great in there so
that didn't work I think what I'm gonna
do is heat up my Jolly Ranchers in a
saucepan and loosen them up until
they're like liquid I have to move
really quickly I'm gonna pour it into
the lined cookie cutter and then also
just streak it on the baking sheet to
create like the shooting effect like a
whoosh and this actually ended up
working oddly enough the green Jolly
Rancher turned this brown color but it
kind of looks like a gold star so I'm
gonna go with it now I'm gonna fry donut
it looks pretty good I'm just coloring
this white flower with some fruit of
color sprinkle waffle sugar have a taste
doesn't have any flavor I melted white
chocolate and coconut oil added very
little food color and these seeds are
great for my donut my cookie is stuck so
I put it back in open is that the gummy
bear yeah
like a trampoline it works you become
yellow but it's kind of cool it just
became very gooey goo in a cookie
wow it's cool yeah it's like a plastic
yeah I'm not happy with it I'm going to
use Donuts on the plate
um under my ice cream Planet as kind of
like Saturn rings we have this cool like
luster spray so I was going to kind of
spray them silver and gold gold leaf
just to be you know fancy the last thing
I have to make is the Galaxy juice I
have pineapple mango and strawberry
like Margarita
Margarita they want to have a drink
makes you crazy crazy I'm giving them
what they want I'm making milkshake my
idea for the drink is to make a sort of
like slushy Vibe I kind of wanted like a
color changing Galaxy Vibe so I'm gonna
flavor lemonade with Kool-Aid packets
I'm pudding pineapple and I put a little
bit of food color mango I have Ube ice
cream so we Blended up some ice spoon
into my glass spray paint this oh my
drink is done maybe I'm trying to
shaking my teeth not sure this cookie is
a good idea so I'm gonna just hide with
other cooking for the flower of my
flower Planet I got these edible flowers
that I thought were really cute I have
wafflecon and I have extra flowers I'm
going to put this on top and then I'm
going to put my Mochi ice cream I think
I'm going to Plate them both just so
they both have a cookie filling the
blank space with some sprinkles my
shooting star has set I'm gonna try to
peel this off okay oh shoot the shooting
star is giving me a lot of trouble which
is a little bit surprising I thought
it'd be one of the easier elements for
my plate but I'm just gonna set it on
top of the drink dust off my ice cream
I'm done how about you I'm done
May the best astronaut win
I'm actually really surprised that I was
able to pull all of my components off
because I was winging this total thing I
think the Galaxy juice will taste good
but I'm a little worried that it's kind
of just melded into one color flower
Planet I think is the star of the show
The Mirror glaze set perfectly on the
cake pop ice cream planet is looking
pretty good I really love how I chose to
spray paint those donuts goals I also
really like how the star cookie turned
out I think it looks a lot like the
picture and I really hope that they like
the filling inside I really hope I win
this one I think it's some of my best
work on the show overall I'm so happy
how it turns out I love my Galaxy much
ice cream it just looked like a little
planet flower Planet it looked like
Blossom alien flowers the Galaxy drink
it's perfectly swirled it looks like a
Milky Way the yellow star cookie even I
hide it underneath the little cookie
with white chocolate looks really pretty
I hope I win
please
oh my God what I recognized
that's the ice cream Planet Audrey we'll
do not like our picture
wait what's the oils what flavor is this
a donut a goat donut okay I want to use
this all day nice okay let's try to
spell cookie
I really like this what is it
um
it tastes really really good I do not
like the fillings
is that channel oh
cake it's so soft Audrey has picked a
couple things that she doesn't like on
my plate so I'm getting a little bit
worried I just ate a flower I like the
space color Auntie it feels like we
should go crazy right now
[Music]
this is already like the lemonade
I'm scared you're gonna go crazy try it
try it
it just tastes like the lemonade
I did not draw this damn they are some
harsh critics I really like the flower
Planet they do the flower Planet video
yes it's little girls oh my God I'm rich
I'm gonna skip dinner okay I'm skipping
dinner I hate to say it but I really
think I got this one
oh my goodness it's just plastic and
this I do not recognize plastic Audrey
said my flower tastes like plastic I
should have heavily seasoned it I
recognize this that's the cricket the
ice cream sandwich it's more strawberry
flavor but I really like it yeah I'm
sleeping it's time to go crazy
it's ice cream
my mission completed she wanted crazy
drink and I made her crazy dance yeah
the flavor now I really like it yes I
love the ice cream except the cheese
part this is the best day yeah
the bread is a little bit too hot it
does not look like my pictures climbing
I don't really you're going to harsh
Audrey
um there were good by doing like the
whipped creams
I only like the cooking wait what
it has honey on it
this is really hard to decide so they
seems like they enjoyed Alex dish more
so I'm losing my confidence
hi
hi
did you guys enjoy yeah
are you crazy
did you like the space dish from Chef
one or Chef two we're gonna say it on
three two one two oh
that's mine I won listen I'm always so
happy for RIA I love her and I am so
happy that she won but damn it
congratulations
thank you so much
oh my God thank you
thank you this is so cute you wrote a
little letter honestly this letter it
feels like a consolation prize it makes
it all worth it so wow how beautiful you
guys are artists all right we have to do
one more thing three two one
[Applause]
[Music]